the last thing we want to do is lose
this cat after
a long journey and all this effort and
all the permitting and everything that's
gone into
getting him here yeah and if you've got
a dart gun right
running full here into this fence
so these are four sidebars three females
and a male so you'll notice that the
male
is the larger
i'm the cheetah meta population
coordinator for the endangered wildlife
trust
but if you want to really break it down
into simpler terms i'm a cheetah
matchmaker
so i effectively identify which cheetah
are related to each other to swap
individuals between these reserves to
prevent inbreeding
[Music]
cheetah have been on the receiving end
of a bad relationship with human beings
for 13 000 years
and the one way to deal with that issue
is to effectively fence humans out
and fence the wildlife in
in the last 100 years the human
population has
increased 20-fold on the continent south
africa is of course
africa's most developed country so it's
particularly difficult
for cheetah to traverse south african
landscape
that's why we have such a dire need to
utilize this approach
a cheetah yeah it's an adult you can
look
yeah i don't go for it yeah and the male
is definitely awake
[Music]
this is the first time that conservation
officials have really attempted to
implement managed metal populations and
we've made a lot of mistakes in the
process we've learned that it's not easy
to relocate wildlife
there's a lot of urgency you know it's
always you are always on the go go go
look at that there's a there's there's
the chat oh thank goodness i was going
120 thank goodness
is that my brother who got stopped there
when we relocate cheetah it often is a
good
20 hour drive
that animal is in the back of your
vehicle and adrenaline's pumping
it can be stressful work sometimes we've
got a big thunderstorm ahead of us
so we're quickly having to mobilize and
cover up these
openings on top of the crates here
because if these cheetah get wet and
trans
especially the wind blowing onto them
they could pick up pneumonia
pneumonia or something like that so
we're going to cover this up and then
hopefully by the time we hit that
approaching storm
these cheetah are going to be able to
stay dry
but nothing can come in from the front
there's enough ventilation from the
sides
we're all good all right
cheetah have been eradicated from 91 of
their historical range in africa
recently their numbers dipped down to 7
000 this implies that they are likely to
be upgraded
to endangered status
[Music]
we as humans have a responsibility to
protect our wildlife
you have certain reserves where the
cheetah population has actually gone
extinct
i don't enjoy transporting cheetah over
large distances in such confined
environments
but this approach is undoubtedly working
we now have successfully reintroduced
cheetah into 53 reserves across the
country
i must be honest i still go through
bouts of nervousness
we've entered a bit of a tricky
situation with this young
cyber adult male he seems to be a little
stressed in that
confined transport crate so um
you know if that behavior persists we're
gonna have to make a very difficult call
of
of possibly releasing him at nighttime
during emergencies we sometimes have to
make the hardcore
of releasing at night when we do that we
try to eliminate the boma
as much as possible with vehicles
yeah boba is a holding facility it's
fully electrified so the cheater cannot
get out of there it's a real fort knox
if he starts running into the sides of
the bomber
then we'll be left with no option but to
immobilize him again
so the first thing we wanted to do is
turn around and try to fight us
[Music]
the eyes looking good nice and relaxed
to be part of the only project that is
seeing an increase in cheetah numbers
it's an absolute privilege
i'm optimistic that this technique will
start to be used in east africa it will
go to central africa
it'll go to west africa hopefully north
africa and possibly even asia in the
future
[Music]
you